all right let's wrap this thing up here
career advice dear
bilexia burr ah
that's a great one and accurate i've
been a high school teacher for the past
seven years but my dream is always to
become
a professional writer oh that's awesome
you know dude that would be a great life
you molded some young minds and then you
became a professional writer
so far he said so far i don't have a
teaching job for the upcoming school
year
i'm considering no longer having my own
classes and instead becoming substitute
teacher for the school year
this would give me more time to write
and submit my work to literary agents
and hopefully get a big publishing deal
i've had some success so far with
writing a published short story and a
nomination for a literary
prize dude what the [ __ ] are you waiting
for
how many more signs of land do you need
this is like columbus when he [ __ ]
sailed over and he saw some tree
branches and a couple of birds
you're gonna get there problem is that
my wife and i still have a lot of
student debt that we're repaying
and substitute teaching does teaching
doesn't pay nearly as much
as being a regular classroom teacher
i've put off my dream
of becoming a writer for years and i
think now maybe the time to
metaphorically
push in all my chips i might lose but i
might win no dude there's no way
there's no way you lose when you go
after a dream
you don't it always leads to something
better always
all right dude [ __ ] substitute
teacher
teach and be a [ __ ] uber driver
all right and you know eat at home more
starving artist i slept on a futon until
i was 36 i don't [ __ ] regret any of
it
i told you that story a zillion times in
this podcast
i was dating this this woman and i said
i had a spot i had to go do and it paid
eight dollars at the comic strip
during the week tuesday night i went
down there and i came back i tried on a
new bit and i was doing a
and afterwards i was at home in my
apartment and i was doing this silly
dance
in the kitchen because i had a new bit
and i was psyched because i had gone
through this period where i wasn't
coming up with any
new material and she was laughing and
then she got a sad look on her face and
i said what's the matter
and she said i wish i had a job
where i only got paid eight dollars yet
i came home and i did a silly dance in
the kitchen
and i never forgot that dude so that you
know what i mean you're gonna have to
suffer a little bit
but uh substitute teach uber dude you
got a short story published and you got
a nomination for a literary prize
come on man you know what you're
supposed to do i don't have to go
through the rest of this [ __ ] thing
he goes my all right i'll get to the
whole thing he said
you know part of me fights against the
dream and insists that i have to do the
responsible thing
and keep teaching [ __ ] all of that [ __ ]
all
the responsible thing to do is to listen
to your heart
uh my question for you either in your
either in your career when you were
trying to build an audience and make it
as a stand-up comedian did you struggle
with the financial strain of chasing
your dream
did you ever have to choose between a
good paying job or doing stand-up
how hard was it to work at a shitty job
just so you could chase your dream
did you ever think that maybe you were
wasting your time any advice or current
i think i answered all of those
um it wasn't hard to work at the shitty
job because i was always thinking about
the exciting job i was going to do
afterwards um
and every night that i just went up on
stage and if it just went
moderately okay i couldn't believe it
i couldn't belie i have to be honest
with you like
i i couldn't [ __ ] believe
that i was actually doing it that i was
actually
i had a dream and i was making it happen
and i still remember the first time i
really
went on stage and i actually got in the
zone
for what was considered a zone at the
level comic i was and i only was in the
zone for about eight seconds
um i was at nick's comedy stop in
framingham
on route 9. it doesn't even exist
anymore
and i just got on this roll of laughter
that i was actually able to pause
and [ __ ] be in the moment and enjoy
it rather than being like oh my god
what's my next joke what's my nest joke
and um that [ __ ] feeling
can carry you through a [ __ ] shitty
job for a week
chasing to get back on stage to feel
that again and then the first time i got
five dollars for gas money freddy stone
i've told all these stories freddie
stone
the excitable boy is what he went by
um i did a room for him and he gave me
five dollars gas money i probably spent
10 to get there and i couldn't [ __ ]
believe it
and i was like i did that and they gave
me this i couldn't [ __ ] believe it
at what point just listen to the sound
of my voice as i'm talking about this
have you ever had that level of
excitement doing any other [ __ ] job
that's what it's like when you're you
you go after
uh a dream job so
nothing nothing is worse than not going
after it
okay and doing the responsible thing and
all of that type of [ __ ] and then you
sit in your house with all your
responsible stuff
[ __ ] all of that is financially i did
not do the responsible thing
and yeah i i've said all these stories i
[ __ ] used to eat spaghetti every
[ __ ] night with a can of [ __ ]
prego
and then a bunch of bread and i would
just fill myself up on that or i go to
denny's and i
get the five stack of pancakes and just
poured my stomach like concrete so i
wouldn't have to eat the whole [ __ ]
day
and do stand up in some cafeteria at
some [ __ ] college
and quitting never entered my mind
i just kept trying to get better at it
because as bad as some of those gigs
were the great ones were way better so
you'll have all of these stories just in
a literary way so
with without a doubt you have to [ __ ]
do it
and um i can tell you right now man like
with what you what you've already
accomplished
like to me i would be thinking like
i'm gonna i can affect way more people
and make way more [ __ ] money and live
a [ __ ] dream
being a professional right i mean right
i mean that'd be unbelievable
be unbelievable so not to say there's
anything wrong with teaching but if
teaching isn't your dream that's just
the job you're doing so i'm not [ __ ]
on teachers out there
it's one of the most underrated jobs and
of course most underpaid jobs
ever um but i'm just trying to amp you
up here
so go out and [ __ ] do it and email me
when you get published because uh
i think you're gonna i don't think you
you know
look if you're a bunch up against bunch
of other [ __ ] writers
and you won one thing but you got two
things going on here all right
give me a [ __ ] break all right you
just need to push yourself out of the
[ __ ] bush
not the bush the nest the bush
that was oddly gross